So now I need to create a second elimination Matrix to
get rid of two.
and then one
so let's do that. I'm going to copy this.
Make it a identity Matrix again.
And let's see what numbers I need to modify in this identity Matrix
to get rid of the two.
Okay.
To get rid of two.
I would have to multiply Row 1 by 2.
And then subtract it from the third row.
So negative 2 plus 2 and I will
get a leading zero.
So what I'm going to do next is
so I need to
multiply
The first row by two and then add it
so yeah multiply the first row by two.
negative 2 rather
and then add it to the third row.
Yeah, I have to be careful.
So this is what I want.
Multiply the first row by negative 2 add it
to the third row.
one more time
There we go.
Now don't worry about the second row because we already have the elimination Matrix
up here.
For the second row. We have the element elimination Matrix. This
is the elimination Matrix for the third row. So as
you can see we've gotten it to become.
A zero, but now there is this negative 3 that also needs
to be a zero.
So I'm going to create a third
elimination Matrix.
I'm going to take this again.
I'm gonna set this back to zero and let me see what number I must
use.
to get rid of negative 3
What do you think?
How do we get rid of that?
Negative 3 in the in the middle of the third
row.
So what I could do.
At 6 over 2. So yes, so at 3 at positive
3 to that but I need to
use one of these so either have to divide this by
two.
or I can multiply this by 1.5 2
times 1.5 gives us 3
so what I can do is multiply.
the first row
by negative
one and a half so three over five is one half.
This is negative 1/2.
And then add that to the third rule so multiply the
first rule by a negative 1.5.
And then add that to the third row.
Okay, hopefully I got this right let me run this and again this needs to
be three.
This needs to be three.
Let me run this one more time.
So this is the original Matrix the identity Matrix.
Multiply a by the identity Matrix. We'll get
the original Matrix this and that are equivalent.
Then I came down here.
I took the original Matrix.
These two are the same this one.
then multiplied three
to the first row
So this would become three three plus minus 3,
this would become zero.
And that's how we get the zero down here.
So the three has been eliminated.
Then let me just copy this Matrix.
So this is the new a
this is the new way.
Okay, the zero has been eliminated, but now
I need to get two to be eliminated.
so to get rid of this two, I'm going
to multiply the first row by
negative 2 so negative 2 plus 2
And this zero.
And the zero disappear so negative 2 plus 2
and then 0 will disappear.
So I'm going to run this.
Okay.
And there we have it.
The zero has disappeared.
Now we're left with this negative 3, so I'm going to copy this.
and then I'm going to
hardcoded
Okay.
So this is where we are now.
The zero has been eliminated here. The zero has been eliminated
here. But now we need to get rid of this negative 3.
So what I can do, well, I have two twos here.
I can use either row two or Row 1.
so
I could use either one of these I could multiply the
second row by 1.5.
And then add it to the third row.
so I can
be careful with my sides here.
I can multiply the second row.
By 1.5. So this becomes three and then
at 3.
To negative 3 to get this to disappear.
Okay, let me try that now.
And there we have it.
So we are now an upper triangle.
One two negative three and zeros here.
So the L triangle that I'm referring to is going
to be the final.
Elimination Matrix. So what do I mean?
Let me take those. Let me take the the three elimination
Matrix matrices that I created. So I'm going
to open a sidebar here.
I'm going to add E1 E2
and E3 down here. So this is E3.
And then this is E2.
And this is E1.
Okay.
The L. Matrix is going to be.
all three of these matrices put together
so we have
1 0 0
then we have three one zero.
three zero
zero
and then
I have a negative 2 here.
And three over two here, so I'm going to put here negative
2.
3 over 2
and then zero, so this is what
I mean by
The L Matrix being the product.
of
a sequence of elimination matrices
and this is what I meant to say and this is what I meant when I
said the
In LED composition we keep track of our operations.
So it's one thing to write down the steps. It's
another thing to put them into matrices like so
Okay.